these are the best cupcakes in london  and this red velvet is my favorite one  [Music]  out of all of those cupcakes the one i  loved the most was the red velvet do you  know which days allah loves out of all  the days throughout the year prophet  salallahu asada said there are no days  on which righteous deeds are more  beloved to allah than these 10 days can  you just imagine giving 100 pounds for  these prayer packs and teaching 10  different people how to praise salah and  it's a sadaqa  meaning it carries on going even when  you are gone just imagine being in your  grave and getting the rewards off 50  salahs coming to you every single day in  your grave you will not be able to come  back to this video to donate so why not  donate now click the button or the link  and donate 10 packs for 100 pounds  [Music]